the first step to change is becoming
conscious of your unconscious self
nobody likes to light a match in a dark
place but if you were going to transform
yourself from the old self to the new
cell first thing you have to do is be
observe your old self you took five
minutes every day and you wrote down two
or three self-limiting thoughts and you
reviewed those thoughts in your mind
over and over again the point you were
so aware of them that they would never
slip by your awareness again in your
waking day the element of rewiring would
actually take place by no longer firing
and wiring if you're not firing and
wiring in the circuits you don't use it
you lose it that's still a rewiring
process if you're aware of what comes
out of your mouth or how you act what
you say what you do it really stands in
the way between you and your future hey
it's Evan Carmichael and I make these
videos because when I started my first
business I really struggled to believe
myself I was making 300 bucks a month
and quit on my business partner and the
thing that saved me was watching the
stories of successful entrepreneurs they
gave me strategies as well as hope and
belief that just maybe I could do it
myself as well and I hope that this
video here today helps you get a little
bit more belief in yourself because I
still need the videos for myself today
too so today let's learn how you can
manifest faster with Joe dispenza enjoy
and you reviewed those behaviors and
actions
to the point where you were so aware of
them now remember the word meditation
means to become familiar with
you're so familiar with the old self you
would never return back to the old self
in other words if you're observing your
old self it means you're not your old
self you're the Consciousness now that's
out of the program observing the old
self you're
objectifying your subjective self
and if you said I am not going to fall
to the level of guilt or pain or
suffering or victimization or
complaining or unworthiness or whatever
it is
fear
and you just became conscious of two or
three emotions that you were going to
stay away from every single day and you
were so familiar with those emotions
that you could sense them coming on
before they came on and you were able to
control them
that is a great way to start the change
now bear in mind
you're going to feel uncomfortable when
you do this because the moment you no
longer make the same choice you just
stepped into that River of change
and so then your body is going to try to
assault you because if 95 of who you are
is your body conditioned as the Mind
once the body doesn't feel comfortable
or doesn't feel familiar it's going to
start sending signals back to the brain
telling you you can it's too hard start
tomorrow
if you know that
the body is craving like like an attic
it's craving certain chemicals
and you are aware of it I think now by
that first step of deciding who you no
longer want to be
the next step is to decide who you want
to be
and just a little effort in thinking
about your energy that day the emotions
you want to live by
who you can forgive how you can change
what you can demonstrate what you'll do
what thoughts you'll think if you keep
firing and wiring those circuits in your
brain and keep creating those elevated
emotions
it will begin to become familiar to you
so I think the process of change then
the first step is unlearning and then
relearning breaking the habit of the old
self and Reinventing a new cell pruning
synaptic connections and sprouting new
connections unmerizing emotions that are
stored in your body then reconditioning
your body to a new mind into a new
emotion so
we already know how to do this by the
way because everybody has changed
something about themselves in their life
and when they've done it they've just
decided about a vision of the future and
they became inspiring when they did they
started to think about the choices they
were going to make the behaviors they
were going to demonstrate the things
they were going to do the experiences or
goals they wanted to have and and how
they would feel but they also thought
about I'm not going to do this I'm not
going to make that choice I'm going to
stay away from these experiences and I'm
not going to feel these emotions we do
this automatically and that is the shift
literally the biological neurological
the chemical hormonal even genetic death
of the old self and then the
reprogramming of the new cell so we
already know how to do this but the
first step to change is not making the
same choices as you did the day before
rule number two is elevate your emotions
if you combine a clear intention and
we've done enough research on this uh
that's a coherent brain there's an
orderly to the brain with an elevated
emotion a coherent heart
you literally begin to move the brain
and body out of the past
into a new future and so do that enough
times
the way you think and the way you feel
begins to create a state of being so if
you begin to push the genetic buttons or
up regulate genes for health and you
down regulate the gene for disease or
what do genes do they make proteins and
proteins are responsible for the
structure and function of your body
any expression of proteins is the
expression of life in the innate
intelligence of the body says hey we're
in an environment where we can heal and
the body has a natural propensity to
want to move back into homeostasis move
back into balance so then the person is
literally changing their state of being
how you think and how you feel is your
state of being so the person goes from
literally being somebody that was
riddled with a disease to changing the
way they think and feel and that her
brain and body looks like the healing
has already occurred and she's not
waiting for the healing to occur to feel
the emotion she's feeling the emotion
and she's living the experience ahead of
it if we do it properly
our biology literally begins to change
and just like in trauma the stronger the
emotion that we feel from some problem
some conditions some event in our life
the more altered we feel inside of us
the more we pay attention to the cause
and the brain freezes a frame and takes
a snapshot and that's called a long-term
memory well what about the inward
process the stronger the emotion the
person feels from an inward experience
the more she remembers the picture in
their mind and you begin to brand that
circuitry in your brain and in a sense
you're remembering your future in the
same way that you remember your past now
thinking neurologically within those
circuits and feeling in the emotions of
the future before it happens is the task
because many people come back to their
senses and they say I'm not healed it
didn't work well you're not that good it
takes time and it takes repetition until
you condition the body
to the mind of that emotion and all you
need is a thought and a Feeling
an image and an emotion of stimulus in
response and you start the conditioning
process and if you do it enough times
you'll never be wondering why you
haven't healed because you'll feel like
you already are healed the moment you
start feeling the other emotions you're
back to the old self looking for when
it's going to happen and where it's
going to happen if you feel the emotion
you feel like it already happens you
wouldn't be separate from the experience
so there's nowhere to look for it so
then the task is to maintain
that modified State of Mind and Body
your entire day with your eyes open and
that's when we get really good at
becoming somebody else rule number three
is create brain heart coherence the more
you become familiar with how you feel
and changing that state of being the
easier it will be for you to do it with
your eyes open as well as your eyes
closed and if you go back to the old
state of being
there's a good probability that your
pain or your condition will come back so
there's this kind of Waltz that goes on
when people are learning how to heal and
change they take a few steps forward and
then a few steps back and then three
steps forward and only one step back and
they had a practice practice
self-regulating they got to practice
what they're paying attention to what
they're unconscious of and
if you if you're stay with it
for a long enough period of time all of
a sudden now the person reaches a point
we've measured what happens where their
chemistry changes so dramatically that
they're literally in love with life now
imagine what happens when oxytocin is
released in the quantities that we see
oxytocin signals nitric oxide nitric
oxide signals a chemical called
endothelial derived relaxing factor and
that's a big word or set of words that
just means a chemical that signals the
arteries in your heart to literally
expand and when they expand you're
getting more blood flow in there and
just like when your sexual organs are
around aroused and there's blood flowing
there now with the same intensity you're
going to feel it right in your heart and
it's going to be way bigger and now the
person's heart is wide open now so
here's the question
huh a person feels those emotions do you
think they're going to want to judge
somebody else in that moment you think
they're going to want to hold a grudge
they're not going to try to forgive
they're going to feel so amazing they're
not going to want to lose this feeling
and they're just going to say I forgive
you I'm not gonna I'm not going to give
this feeling up because of you now
now that's the side effect
of true transformation the side effect
is a greater level of Consciousness the
side effect is a greater skill set in
life and and I think that when you start
getting good at this then all the things
you thought you wanted you no longer
want because when you're creating more
brain and heart coherence you feel more
whole and the more whole you feel the
less you live and lack so how could you
want
many things if you feel whole it feels
like you already have them and and
that's actually when you start to see
those wonderful Miracles those
synchronicities those serendipities
those coincidences happening in a person
those are experiences coming to them
that's the field dropping bread
breadcrumbs saying keep going
keep going and there's a synchronization
between that person's energy and their
future and the side effect of that are
signs uh and and that's when it gets to
be exciting because every sign does what
it creates an enthusiasm and excitement
you're kind of going hey there's another
sign I'm going to go do it again so now
you're not going oh I have to meditate
today oh geez I gotta create my life
you're looking forward you're like oh my
God I don't want the magic to stop
happening I'm going to get into it in
every synchronicity creates that
elevated emotion and you use that energy
for the next creation and people climb
out of their lives climb climb out of
their past yeah also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video I've designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet
designed specifically for this video
absolutely for free there's a link in
the description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
rule number four is fall in love with
the future so you're saying hold on to
that vision of the Future No Matter What
yeah if you keep your conscious mind on
what you want your subconscious mind
will take you there period and then you
in your teaching you talk about it shows
up sometimes in ways that are unexpected
sometime or always well if you are in
the process of taking time out of your
busy life to emulate the Divine to
emulate the Creator then you can't be a
victim if you're creating in order to
create something unlimited you have to
feel Unlimited in order for you to
emulate the Divine you have to become
Divine in order for you to be a Creator
you must feel like a Creator now let me
finish yeah because this is an important
element because if you took time out of
your busy life every single day to allow
that intelligence to work with you
that's both personal and Universal
within you and all around you
and you made contact with him
it's all around us but we can't use our
senses to experience it then if you said
to this intelligence okay look I took
time out of my busy life today to be
like you I'm a child of you and I want
to be like you and so I want to create
something new in my life but look
I am such a articulate ego I want you to
bring it in a way that I least expect
why because if you can expect it it's
nothing new it's got to be a surprise
it's got to rock your world it's got to
catch you off guard and it has to leave
no doubt that what you did inside of you
produce that effect outside of you and
when you can correlate the changes you
made inside of you with the effect that
you produced outside of you you'll pay
attention to what you did and you'll do
it again so the synchronicities the
serendipities the coincidences are then
begin to come back to us and it's those
things that capture our attention and we
get a little rush of energy and that
little rush of energy should be that
you're headed in the right direction to
inspire you to continue creating now the
brain learns by mistakes and learns by
surprises which would you rather have a
few of a good surprise yes
but that is such a hard moment because
when the new comes in the old
personality may not even recognize it
because it's so used to its old pattern
how do we start to become available to
recognizing the unknown
you have to take time to keep creating
if you keep your conscious mind every
single day on that vision and not on the
news and not on your suffering and not
on your pain and not on your past but
you put all of your attention on that
Vision where you place your attention is
where you place your energy and if you
invest enough of your energy in your
future your body is going to be drawn to
that experience and you are going to
know that experience is for you and
you're going to know that you created it
now
in the beginning
it's like getting a compass to True
North and there's all kinds of weird
Fields going on that's normal but
imagine if you took as much time
to invest in your future as you did
spending on certain emails and you were
passionate about it and you were clear
about it and you wrote everything down
and you dreamed about it and you worked
on it you would start getting downloads
from nowhere you would start getting
information out of nowhere and you would
start understanding exactly what you're
doing on a deeper level now I don't care
if you're talking about the Wright
brothers Colonel Sanders I don't care if
you're talking about
Nelson Mandela I don't care who you're
talking about that that impacted the
world in some way everybody every one of
those people had alone time every one of
those people were dreaming every one of
those people believed in that future so
here's the question
can you believe in a future that you
can't see or experience yet but you've
thought about enough times in your mind
that your brain has literally changed to
look like the experience has already
occurred and can you fall in love with a
future potential a future reality to
such a degree that your body as the
unconscious mind begins to believe it's
living in that future reality in the
present moment the physiology of the
future is already impacted it and you're
signaling new genes in new ways and new
neural Nets of uh understanding to
change not only your brain but your body
begins to change to look like the
experience has already occurred now
think about this I do I have I mean yeah
I know if your brain and body have
physical evidence that it has already
happened this is where you can relax
rule number five is get outside of time
we really think that you know
everything's going to be handed to us or
we can get whatever we want nothing's
wrong with that that's really cool
that's really great but in the creative
process
um you actually have to get outside of
time
in order for you to be able to create
because if you're trying to predict
what's going to happen in the next
moment if you keep Romancing what
happens you're not in the present moment
The Familiar past is the known the
predictable future is the known
the present moment is the unknown that
is where all possibilities exist so yes
there is a function of three-dimensional
reality and Technology where more things
are happening in a shorter amount of
time certainly there's some type of
energetic thing that's taking place uh
in so many ways and to me that energy is
actually endorsing whoever you want to
be that's what I believe so if you want
to be a victim get ready because it's
going to get really good for you because
that energy is more available if you
want to heal wow there's a lot of people
healing now and they're using that
energy instrumentally in a positive way
so so yes there's a quickening that's
taking place and it's creating quite a
contrast or extremes that are taking
place in reality and the more extreme it
gets the more unstable the system right
so uh governments
um
um journalism
education religion medicine
uh everything's kind of Fallen apart you
know um and and it's very obvious to
people that has to happen for a new
Consciousness to emerge the thing is
we can't face these changes
uh programmed because we'll just add to
uh the chaos we actually have to be
relaxed and awake instead of stressed
out and unconscious and we have the data
to show that when you're relaxed and
awake amazing things can actually happen
to you instead of in survival stressed
out and in a program so in order to
create out something new we got to be we
got to be in the present moment and we
have to be outside that pace of where
everything's moving very quickly and and
Technology unfortunately is causing
people it's causing people to think uh
uh instead of them for them to think on
their own and I'm concerned about that
because
um
I never tell people what to think I I
want them to think for themselves I
think it's really important for us to
think for ourselves so there's an
acceleration that's taking place
energetically but I do think that that
acceleration is really just endorsing uh
uh who who you're being so Master the
moment and and learn how to be a Creator
uh I think that amazing things happen
and that's exactly what we're
discovering over and over again in just
witnessing the science
is absolutely supporting that that you
are greater than you think more powerful
than you know more unlimited than you
can ever dream we have the data over and
over again that suggests that and the
testimonials that we have in hundreds of
people we have cancer researchers
standing on the stage with cancer
completely gone we see stage four
cancers and bones and organs and liver
in the lungs com metastatic cancer just
doesn't typically go away
um very easily and out of the bones
there's no sign of it anywhere I mean
not once not twice over and over again
we had two people at an event that were
blind item number six the last one
before some very special bonus Clips is
break your bad habits for the audience
that I listen right now and and feel
like yeah I want to empower this I want
to do these tools what should I do is it
like they have to meditate every day is
it like to have to work with their
negative thoughts or what is the steps
what should they do
okay let's break it down really simply
okay
your personality creates your personal
reality
that's it
and your personality is made up of how
you think
how you act
and how you feel so the present
personality who's listening to this
podcast has created the present personal
reality called their life
so if you believe what I just said then
in order for you to create a new
personal reality a new life you're gonna
have to change your personality in other
words nothing changes in your life until
you change that's the way it is
so it turns out the 90 of the thoughts
that we think on a daily basis are the
same thoughts as the day before
same thoughts lead to the same choices
same choices lead to the same behaviors
same behaviors create the same
experiences the same experiences produce
the same feelings and the same emotions
and those same feelings and emotions
begin to influence our very same
thoughts and our biology
our neural circuitry our neural
chemistry are hormones our gene
expression our immune system
all stay the same because we're staying
the same so then there's a principle in
Neuroscience that says that nerve cells
that fire together wire together you
keep thinking the same thoughts they
keep making the same choices you keep
doing the same things you keep creating
the same experiences that stamp the same
networks of neurons into the same exact
patterns all for the reaffirming of the
same feeling and you do that for 10
years on end
the firing and wiring of those
circuitries begins to hardwire the brain
into a very finite signature that box in
the brain that's created is the same
level of mind and if you keep doing that
it becomes automatic
and turns out that 95 of Who We Are by
the time we're in the middle of our life
is a set of memorized behaviors
automatic emotional reactions constant
habits hardwired attitudes beliefs
perceptions
that have happened just because we've
we've just fired and wired it the same
way so there's a good possibility then
in order for us to change we better
start thinking about what we've been
thinking about and changing we have to
become conscious of our unconscious
habits and behaviors and modify them we
got to look at these feelings that we
feel every single day instead of just
thinking it's a feeling say what is this
is this guilt is this sadness is this
unhappiness is this pain is it
frustration is it resentment what is the
feeling that I'm living by the majority
of my day now
that's lighting a match in a dark place
in Neuroscience is called metacognition
the word meditation means to become
familiar with that's what it means so
the more familiar with you are I can't
with I can't it's too hard I'm never
going to change it's my ex's fault it's
my boss's fault it's my country's fault
it's the government it's the weather
it's my pain whatever that thought is
that you accept believe and surrender to
on a daily basis that's automatic
you have to become so conscious of that
unconscious thought
that it doesn't slip by your awareness
unnoticed you got to catch yourself
saying I'm tired I'm unhappy that
someone else's fault do you complain do
you blame do you make excuses do you
feel sorry for yourself that that
personality
has to change in order to create a new
life so then you have to become so aware
of your unconscious habits that you
don't go unconscious to them in your
waking day then you gotta sit in the
fire of those emotions
and you gotta watch those emotions come
up and you have to sit with them and
know that there's something on the other
side of them now this is where most
people get up and say I can't meditate
or I'm going to call up my friend or I'm
gonna get on social media and make a
post I'm gonna turn on the football game
I'm gonna get distracted because I need
something out there to make this go away
and what we're saying is we're not
relying on anything out there that's the
that's the hypnosis that's the
conditioning we want you to just become
so familiar with that feeling that you
catch yourself in your waking day the
moment you start
feeling sad and your energy drops ah you
catch yourself so
there's an unlearning process or
breaking the habit of being the old self
process that requires
a lot of attention
a lot of awareness and it takes energy
you gotta stay conscious right so that
unlearning process then
the hardest part about change
is not making the same choices you did
the day before and the moment you decide
to make a different Choice get ready
because you're going to feel
uncomfortable it's not familiar it's
going to feel yucky it's going to feel
unpredictable it's not going to feel
good because even people who feel sad
and suffering at least they can feel
that and that's familiar to them so
you're stepping out of the known into
the unknown now
if you've done something so many times
that your body now knows how to do it
better than your mind that's a habit so
then
the body who's been conditioned into
negativity into sadness into suffering
into pain all of a sudden is saying hey
Alex um it's been two hours since you've
been complaining I mean you've been
complaining for the last 20 years you're
just gonna stop like that so the body
starts trying to influence the mind to
return back to the same familiar
territory so the emotion starts saying
come on you're a loser you'll never
change your it didn't work last time
start tomorrow and and those are the
thoughts that are being influenced for
the body that are the same thoughts that
people think all the time so if they
respond to that thought that thought's
going to lead to the same choice that
same choice is going to lead to the same
behavior the same behavior is going to
create the same experience the same
experience is going to produce the same
feeling and they're going to say
oh this feels right well no it feels
familiar the person who's Crossing that
River
from the old self to the new self that
place that discomfort is not the known
it's the unknown and that
is the perfect place to create him
everything is possible you know when you
believe that's
the kind of kicker you have to believe
but it's not that hard it's really
pretty easy
our belief creates our entire life
experience and so you can't if I put it
this way you can't experience anything
in life
that is outside of your own beliefs
so and that's that's the case for every
single one of us we really can't
experience anything that's outside of
our beliefs if we can't experience
anything that's outside of our beliefs
what that means is look at all those
hearts that's so beautiful
what that means is there's not really
one world we kind of think there's one
world but there isn't really because
we're all experiencing a world based on
our beliefs and not one of us has the
same beliefs not one of us so that means
there's a different world for every one
of us
so all of your beliefs are held in your
subconscious mind and the subconscious
mind is just a part of your mind there's
the conscious mind and then there's the
subconscious mind who's actual which is
actually higher than the conscious mind
and so we use our conscious mind with
all of the thoughts and everything that
we have our conscious mind is very
present right and so
to create anything
you are using your subconscious mind
your subconscious mind is what is really
what creates if I want to make it really
really simple then I would say the
subconscious mind is what creates
it makes things appear and manifest
things and that's where all of your
beliefs are still kind of neat huh
because you have to believe to manifest
something and your subconscious mind
creates everything so you can see it's
all kind of perfectly designed
so now to manifest you have to believe
and you have to believe that you already
have whatever it is that you want and
the reason that you have to believe you
have it already is because the
subconscious mind is only operating in
the present it can't reason it's just
like a program so if you say for example
um a new car is coming my new car is
coming I'm going to get a new car it's
coming well then it's always going to be
coming right that that's the thing you
have to imagine you have it now you have
to go off and you have to test drive the
car you've got to feel the car smell the
car and just then visualize being in
that car and then when you do that
that's how
if you do that enough that's how you'll
come to believe that you actually have
the car and the moment that you believe
there's manifestations instantaneous
so so the other ways to believe is to
affirm over and over and over
um so to be really repetitive for
example
um to visualize and visualizing is
incredibly powerful because when we
close our eyes and we put ourselves in
the picture and you must make sure
you're in the picture and you put
yourself in the picture with whatever it
is that you want and you close your eyes
and you just kind of create this mini
movie honestly
the subconscious mind does not know that
you're imagining it has no idea it just
sees that movie and recreates it it's
like a giant photocopying machine it
will just whatever you hold in your mind
it will
photocopy it warm into the world so
um so if you are thinking about
something in the future it's always
going to be in the future so you have to
imagine that you have it now you have to
act as if and for example if you wanted
to attract a perfect partner are you
acting as if your perfect partner's here
already and so there are just small
things that you can do that are super
super powerful for example are you
sleeping in the middle of your bed or
are you sleeping on one side of the bed
because your partner's on the other side
of the bed do you have room in your
wardrobe for your perfect partner's
clothes is there room in your bathroom
for their toothbrush and for their
things and so you see they are just
little things you can set the table for
two you don't have to put food on the
plate but just setting the table for two
is really really powerful it's saying my
perfect partner's here already and the
subconscious mind will believe it and
your perfect partner will be attracted
to you through the most incredible
circumstances so
um if something hasn't manifested yet
and you really really want it and I I
doubt there's anybody out there who's
who wants something and it hasn't
manifested right I mean
um I'll tell you the reason why it
hasn't manifested is because you don't
believe you have it do you speak about
the neurophysiology of forgiveness
sure
think about
Frozen circuits
Frozen circuits are hardwired circuits
the more profound the insult
to the person
that is connected to a strong emotion
the more the brain freezes circuitry
the more we think about the experience
the more we fire and wire the circuits
in our brain yes or no
and the more we remember the event the
more we produce the emotions that are
associated with it and we're
conditioning the brain and body further
into the past yes or no and that you
keep doing it enough times it's no
longer conscious that you're holding a
grudge
it's no longer conscious
that you're stuck
it's now you're seeing everybody through
the lens of that experience and
everybody's a betrayer
everybody can't be trusted everybody is
that same person you're you're
overlaying
the memory of re of your experience into
reality you're not seeing it the way it
is you're seeing that person wearing the
mask of the last person
that's the lens that we're perceiving
reality are you with me still
and so then anything in your life that
becomes remotely close to it based on
your limited perception triggers the
emotion in the network and you're back
in your past and you're acting like you
were when it happened are you with me
still
and so then the person says I'm not that
person and you say oh no I know I just
had this event in my past and I'm sorry
and then it's excusable but then here it
happens again
and there's nothing wrong with this
we all do it it's just how do we
overcome it
so then
you're sitting and doing the work
and you're you're moving energy up those
centers you're releasing the life force
into your brain
you are blessing those centers and
taking a scoop and moving it all the way
up and releasing it all the way up into
the field you're opening the channel
you're unfolding is nobody no one no
thing nowhere and no time and the
identity and the personality is gone
which energy is going to move Scott to
what's going to follow the path
you're opening your heart once it gets
to your heart it's going to make its way
all the way up and when you feel love
and compassion
when you feel true true kindness and
care it's hard to hold the grudge
are you with me still yes so then from a
quantum physics point of view
you have that person always in the back
of your mind right you have the event
and the memory rolling around back there
because the very thing that you don't
want to have happen you're already
preparing for emotionally
are you with me still yeah so then from
a Quantum perspective you are actually
as a creator of reality holding yourself
hostage because of that person
and you are holding them hostage because
of that experience and you have an
energetic Bond that's connecting you to
them
and you're sharing the same energy
and so then you're using each other to
reaffirm whatever that energetic
agreement is
are you with me still
so then
when you forgive someone it's because
there's been a strong change in your
emotional state
because the emotion is what's keeping
you energetically bound to them or to
more than one person
and so then once you start lowering the
volume to that emotion and the body
starts liberating energy and you're
calling your energy back to you because
the lower the volume of the emotion the
less you're going to pay attention to
that person there comes a moment where
there's a snap there's a release the
energy is broken and once it's broken
now all of a sudden you free yourself
and you free them and this has happened
to me in my life that people show up 10
years later completely changed and so
humble and so asking for forgiveness
just because they had transformed and
and I let them go
so then
forgiveness
from a Quantum perspective in a
neurophysiological perspective is just
taking your attention off them that's
all it is and when you start getting
happy with yourself
and you start feeling those elevated
emotions because you're striving for
that you wouldn't trade this for The
Grudge you were holding because this
feels too good are you with me still now
once that heart opens up
and you start having energy in the
center and it's releasing 1300 to 1400
different chemicals that begin to
restore and regenerate the body the
bodies start getting a lift of energy
once it makes it's here now you're going
to see that track sending in energy to
the brain the heart acts as an amplifier
to boost the brain are you with me still
so then once the Energy starts making
its way into the brain once the heart
starts to open we've measured this with
our students they have oxytocin levels
rise
once you start feeling oxytocin and you
feel more love then you feel The Grudge
so then you think
why would I want to give this up for
that person
that's called forgiveness you don't have
to try to do it
it just is a side effect of your
personal transformation and oxytocin
then
when it's released rushes right into the
amygdala the survival center of the
brain and the research is outstanding
and the first thing it does is it fits
in the same receptor sites as fear and
it lowers the volume to fear and anxiety
it shuts the lights out for aggression
and anger and hostility and it cools the
circuits off for suffering and pain and
the only thing you can feel is a love
for life and that's when you're free now
the practice of forgiveness
matter to matter you can do it but it
takes a long time and a lot of work and
then you forgive and then you're like I
don't want to forgive him yet
halfway forgiven
and just never really authentic
forgiveness do you understand
and you know there was a woman that came
to our work
and
she was raped by four men
and when she was a teenager
and it was abusive
and she had severe severe night terrors
severe
anxiety and panic attacks she had cyclic
mood problems she had been to every
single doctor every single healer every
single alternative practitioner nothing
changed it
came to our event in
in Tacoma Washington
and she hit that point where she became
everybody everyone everything everywhere
every time every place she became the
Oneness
and and that frequency had a message for
her and it said and she was an
incredible Bliss when this happened
I sent four Angels disguised as rapists
for this moment
and that was the end of her tariffs
that was the end of her night she
couldn't have a relationship she
couldn't she could not live with anybody
she was she was isolated
one moment the Divine stepped in
and gave her the signal that was
carrying a very specific message and she
got the download not just that
not just the thought
she got the energy move right through
her body and she saw the whole thing
and that moment
is what she was waiting for that's what
the soul was waiting for now she's
healed she's healthy she's happy and
she's on with a new life she's born
again so my mother would love this she's
born again in the same life reborn in
the same way didn't pass to a birth
canal for it
she just was born again in the same way
she got a new lease in one instant that
energy was carrying a message and it
made its way all the way into the body
and the Bliss and the joy and the
Gratitude and the love that she felt
and the message that was carried would
made total sense to her
she's free one instant to me that's true
forgiveness
that's the Divine having its way with
you I think one of my first things in
failure
is don't take it more personally than it
actually is and I'll give an example of
that when I was applying to 40 companies
that all rejected me before an interview
yeah all I was getting was an automated
response saying your application will
not go any further
can't take that personally because they
didn't meet me in person they didn't
have a interaction with me they just saw
my name they saw I'd been a monk for
three years that resume is useless I
mean what's your transferable skills
like sitting in silence
surprise surprise no one wants to hire a
monk and so they rejected you but that's
not personal because they didn't meet me
in person but what if they had me right
so that's the first thing the first step
is don't take all fear failure I'll give
an example me and you we reach out to
countless guests to be on our podcast
which they know all the time we're
saying all the time but if I don't hear
a no from the guest directly that's not
a no like someone's team can say no
someone's assistant can say no someone's
PR team can say no but until they say no
personally it's not a no okay but when
they do say no then that's enough yeah
so then let's move how do you deal with
that type of failure yes so if I deal
with a failure where someone meets me in
person and gets to know no Jay you're
horrible you sucked like I don't want to
deal with a monk ever in my life yeah I
would never go on your show I'm never
listening to you never yeah then how do
you deal with that type of so I've had
you say this I've said it a couple of
times and I'm sure it's been repeated a
bunch of times around how I genuinely
believe failure has feedback feedback
and and so for me it's like failure has
the ability to actually tell you what
you need to improve now not to improve
to get their attention
improving to get the actions that you
want to take yeah the results you want
the results you want and don't make that
result about the person who said no
don't try use failure as a way to prove
someone else wrong because what happens
when we prove what others wrong when you
prove others wrong you end up trying to
get validation and approval for them and
now if they're not impressed when you're
right you lose again so you end up
losing twice and you spend all this time
and energy years maybe to prove
something wrong I've been there many
times and then you're like I felt good
for a moment yeah and then I feel empty
again totally and and so that's the
thing about failure in the second half
is you have to see failure as an
improvement if if I'm completely honest
everyone who rejected me in my life up
until now
has made me more hungry taught me so
much more about myself and made me up my
game yeah and I think if failure doesn't
make you up your game it's the same as
losing in a sport
right when you fail and you've lost
games and you've won games you know on
the big stages you didn't have the
skills you didn't have the teamwork you
guys weren't hungry enough you were
communicating enough there's something
you were missing yeah so you go review
the game film you check the stats you
see what could have done better and you
try to improve that for the next game
yeah I think a lot of people can do that
in life but we're so afraid to like go
on the next game of life like I got
rejected once and it hurts so bad yeah
how do people learn to overcome that
pain of rejection yeah to keep going
yeah you know in sports luckily there's
a season which like you might have 30
basketball games after you lose the
first two you don't say uh I'm just
gonna give up the rest of the season
yeah you keep playing yes but in life a
lot of people stop playing yeah why yeah
I think that's great mental training too
I think Sports is great mental training
because you have to show up to the next
game even if you lost and you don't feel
bad exactly that you don't feel good
sorry and and one of the things before I
dive into that question one of the
things that you reminded me of was that
the Lost dance documentary so there's
that season that Michael Jordan everyone
is agreement in agreement that he is one
of the best players to be playing and
they keep losing no need to make a fight
they didn't make the finals they lost
and then they realized they need to get
the team and they need to find their I
think they're bringing Dennis Rodman and
then they start bringing in all these
other players that strengthen whereas if
they would have just said oh we got the
best player in the world we just keep
doing this
I'm not sure what they would have got
there right but the coach Phil Jackson
and the team they had to adapt and so
you're saying why do we feel that pain
in rejection and how do we deal with
that
I think we feel that pain because we
look at a failure right we look at it as
a complete definition of us right we're
looking at as as uh there's that famous
statement of like you know failure is an
event not a person right and I don't
know who said it but it's one of those
statements that that really clicks like
failure is uh an event not a person
whereas we start thinking we are the
failure like we say I am
and in 1925
physicists said that our vision of a
universe split into an invisible energy
realm and a material Physical Realm was
a total illusion that everything is
energy the whole thing there is no
matter in this world and to summarize
what the meaning was of famous
physicists in 1930 by the name of Sir
James jeans said we have been led to
believe that the universe is a great
machine when in fact it is more a great
thought
and the reality about that was quantum
physicists have established since 1925
that Consciousness is the primary
mechanism of creativity of the world
that we experience in fact a more recent
article in the journal Nature which is
like a a scientific mainstream Journal
was an article by a Quantum physicist at
Johns Hopkins University by the name of
Richard con Henry and his article was
entitled the mental universe
I I know the last two lines in the
article because they were like so
powerful and here's what the conclusion
of the article was
the universe is immaterial it's mental
and spiritual live and enjoy and this is
so exciting because science is coming
out saying it mental and spiritual is
like oh my God but that's the quantum
physics part and the reality about it
why is that and so important as uh sad
Vijaya just mentioned it's our thoughts
that are manifesting this world now you
can say that's a spiritual thing and now
I say not only is it spiritual now it is
fundamental basic science of the
universe and it says then the thoughts
are creative well if the thoughts are
creative then who is having the thought
and you start to realize I'm having the
thought well then the truth is simple as
Richard con Henry said you were creating
this world with your mental activity and
your spirituality combined and then all
of a sudden it says well then if I'm
creating the world then my original
belief that when things didn't go right
I was a victim the universe wasn't
supporting me you know it's like oh I
try so hard and the universe is not
giving me things it turns 180 degrees
around and it basically says this
we are creating this world
and then I say your mind is creating
this world and then I give you the
science that says there are two minds
that are operating at the same time one
is called the conscious mind of one is
called the subconscious mind I say
What's the difference
the conscious mind is where you are as a
spirit an entity a unique identity you
are in that conscious mind and
perceiving the world I said what about
the subconscious mind it's not a
creative mind the subconscious mind is
habits things that you've learned and
you've experienced in your life and they
become habits so uh the subconscious
mind is not thinking creating a
subconscious mind push the button play
the behavior
so here's the point
when we are in our conscious mind we are
connecting our spirituality to the
biology and the physical planet that
we're in and that is a creative mind
that's the one you wake up in the
morning and say oh I wish I had this and
I desire that and these are the things I
want and then you go out and start the
day and then guess what
95 of the day you are not operating from
the conscious mind science is recognized
95 of the day because we are thinking 95
percent of the day our behavior is now
controlled by the subconscious mind I go
okay so what's the difference in the
final conclusion of this is the
conscious mind with your creativity has
your wishes and your desires
the subconscious mind was programmed by
other people your mother your father
your siblings and your community so what
is the difference you wake up with a
wish and a desire of what you want
and then the rest of the day you play
the programs that you got from other
people that don't answer your wishes and
don't support your desires and all you
see is the consequence of it and go oh
my God why is it not working the answer
is because you don't see because
remember the name is subconscious below
conscious so when that behavior is
playing
psychologists will tell us 70 percent or
more of the programs in the subconscious
are disempowering
self-sabotaging and limiting behaviors
so the simple reality is this we have
great wishes and desires and yet our
life is not controlled by them our life
is controlled by the programming and
that programming is the disempowering
program so all you see is the
consequence of the invisible
subconscious which will sabotage all the
desires and wishes you have and then to
conclude that
what if you just didn't default to the
subconscious what if you just stayed in
the conscious mind that's called being
Mindful and why is it relevant because
when you stay conscious keep your mind
present you are the creator of your life
and when people are in mindfulness they
manifest their wishes their desires and
their happiness so for all of us it's
sort of a wake-up call you think you're
running your life with your wishes and
desires it's an illusion you're really
running your life with your programs
acquired from other people most people
are victims because of choice or because
of expectations people expect to be
victimized they think
they think they're not very strong and
they're not very capable or they they
don't have very high aspirations that's
if there's anything that I think people
suffer from in this country it's that
not that they fail to achieve so much is
that they fail to Aspire they don't have
a sense of their own internal capacities
and greatness or abilities to handle
just about any situation well we've
talked about that before but how can a
book tell you how to do this well a book
can't do it for you I'm the first one to
admit to say that absolutely just like
going to a psychiatrist a psychiatrist
cannot make your life any better I'm
convinced of that nor can a valium or
anything like that it has to be
something that you do internally
yourself it can provide your guidelines
it's very much like if you your car
breaks down and you got your repair
manual there you say well why isn't this
manual fixing my car manuals don't fix
cars they can just give you the
information you either do it to yourself
or you don't but can the book give you a
way to rate yourself as far as what how
how victimized you you really are yeah I
I think so uh a lot of people are very
critical of books and self-help books
and whether or not they can really be
helpful to people and so on and I know
in my own life I've been really
influenced by some very significant
writing of people who've lived before me
a lot of poets uh a lot of the great you
know even Mark Twain reading people
books have really influenced my life
these kinds of books influence people's
lives today I know it from the mail that
I get and uh well what's step one
so after you've read the book step one
is to change your expectations around
like every situation you go into all
right you got who victimizes people the
most in our culture family members you
know uh your parents telling you that
you ought to be the way they want you to
be your uh your children telling you
that they expect you to make their
lunches for them they expect you to pick
after the up after them and so on uh uh
bureaucrats our government uh clerks
people like that waiters tipping when
you're getting bad service all of these
kinds of things you just change around
your expectations you say I am not going
to allow this person or this institution
to get me I'm not going to try to change
it for the whole world but Wayne How to
specifically I feel sorry for mothers
who are victimized every day I mean my
husbands and by kids you know they have
no they have no self left they give
everything and they but they've taught
themselves that they said to their
husbands or their children uh it's okay
you can push me around if you want to
get uh angry at me or upset at me then
I'll take that and I believe you get
treated in life the way you teach people
to treat you if you've taught people
that you're going to be a dish rag or
you're going to be somebody who's going
to clean up all the time and you're not
going to have any esteem for yourself
then naturally people are going to come
along and just do that but it's a desire
to be approved to be loved so now you're
saying No More Mr Nice Guy I don't think
people are loved I think it's a myth
that you that you love dish Rags or that
you love people I I think people respect
strength not weakness and you stand up
to somebody you say what's really on
your mind and that first people will
feign it you know they'll fake it they
say oh my God you've really hurt my
feelings that's a strategy that's a
technique to get you you know if I can
get you to come over and visit me on
Sunday by using guilt you know and
saying oh if you don't visit me you know
it's okay I went through 18 hours of
child labor but that's okay
and I can use all of this stuff and
you'll come well I'm going to continue
to use that but if you say wait a second
you know I've got a right to decide
where I'm going to be on Sunday and I'm
I can't be there this Sunday and you're
firm about that you know what happens is
after a while people respect you more
what happens at work though when you go
down and tell that to your boss the very
same thing I'm talking about it you're
fired no no hardly ever and even if you
are it's generally for the better uh
even on the job people respect strength
you don't want somebody on the job who's
always going to be a yes man who's
always going to you know if you're
trying to run the show and you want to
know how things are going and what the
reactions are and you've got a lot of
yes men around you which is like what
Nixon had around him everybody's just
going around saying yes sir yes and you
find that the show's ratings are going
down and down and down because people
aren't being willing to be honest with
you you want to have a producer a
director or staff people who are going
to say look this is what you're doing
that's not working this is what's
effective you don't have to be nasty
yeah but we expect that but the question
I have is if you've set a pattern in
your household as a mother or even in a
relationship with a man or vice versa
and you've you've been the giver and the
nice guy all of a sudden when you make
that change then don't people pull back
and say wait you don't love me anymore
yeah they do and that's a technique too
that's a strategy to get you to go back
to uh being a slave again and when they
when you suddenly say to them I'd love
it has nothing to do with love it has to
do with my interest in being my own
person and you're you're using guilt
saying you know you don't love me isn't
going to work anymore how many women how
many times in your life have you gone
out with a man when you were dating or
if you're dating now uh have somebody
called you up and you know you don't
want to go out with this person you know
you nice guy everything is but you know
there's nothing there and you can't say
no yeah and you just say oh wow and then
there there you are three weeks later
you're going out on a date and you're
and this guy is coming on to you and all
and you just saying what am I doing here
I know and learning how to just say no
you know I don't want to go and he said
well you know you're hurting my feelings
and I'll probably have to put my head in
the oven and you know any numbers all
right all right I'll go I'll go you know
anything you know and this is the you
know that's a victim status you've got
to learn not to make commitments for
things and actually what you're saying
be a little selfish huh selfish not
inconsiderate yes but selfish definitely
in this long time yeah it's your life
it's your time it's the only shot you
get at this life and why should anybody
else run it for you oh it seems like an
awful lot of selfish people in the world
already well selfish when you you
selfish generally you mean inconsiderate
you know stepping on other people not
caring about others I don't believe in
that I don't do that myself I spend most
of my life in the service of other
people but it's because if you love
yourself you can you can give love away
if you if you can't give away what you
don't have if you don't okay that's step
one No More Mr Nice Guy number two
it's like going out and practicing you
know uh really standing up for the
things you know somebody's out there uh
go practice being insulted in fact it's
necessary but but it isn't necessary you
know I have a thing called being quietly
effective John and it's like you know a
lot of people misconstrue their goals in
life they pull into a gas station right
and they want their windshield washed
the guy is too busy he doesn't care he's
not interested he doesn't wash your
windshield this person who wants his
windshield what forgets his goal is just
to have a windshield wash that's all he
now says I'm going to reform that guy
how dare he treat me that way who does
he think and he's gonna and this guy's
behavior is suddenly controlling them
emotionally and your goal is just to
Simply say look would you mind washing
my windshield you don't have to give a
lecture if the guy says look I'm too
busy you say well now I'm going to talk
to the manager or whatever you know you
go on to the next step or you get out
and wash it yourself it's necessary but
you don't allow other people's behavior
to be the controlling thing of your
emotions in your life whether that's
that clerk there or whether it's your
husband or your children well you said
you said about explanation what about
people that feel like they've got to
give a long drawn out explanation with a
thousand reasons and excuses they become
victims you know and then somebody at
the end you know what they'll say I just
don't understand you
that's straighten up I better go back
and I better start watching as I'm
confident versus cocky I mean confident
versus insulting I mean is there a fine
line you have to learn that the the very
specific line confident means standing
up for what you believe cocky or abusive
or conceited means trying to convince
other people of how terrific you up if
you run your life on your inner signals
you don't have any need to show anybody
else how great you are if you're
confident you just simply do it you need
to create an environment of Excellence
Excellence most people's environments
are not excellent the people around you
the the videos that you watch the things
that are on your wall the voices that
are in your head you have these moments
that are bold that are courageous that
make you feel Unstoppable and you can do
anything and then you fall back down
because the environment is the thing
that's keeping you small it takes a
giant effort to overcome your
environment you definitely can it's
definitely possible tons of people are
doing it but it takes that giant effort
to say I don't want to stay stuck here
most people stay stuck most people make
minimal minimal minimal improvements in
their life year over year
and if you don't want to stay where you
are right now fast forward to one year
from today you don't want to stay stuck
you want to be in a different place it
could actually be physically moving but
a different place in terms of your
finances in terms of your purpose in
terms of how much you're giving and
caring and sharing and the life that you
want to build you want to be somewhere
totally different like today this is not
acceptable anymore I accept that this is
where I am right now but where I end up
is not going to be the same spot as
where I am right now right if that's
your commitment the biggest shift that
will help you get from where you are now
to where you want to be is creating that
environment of Excellence what's the
fastest way to learn a language what's
the fastest way to learn Japanese well
it's to go to Japan sure you can read
some books and and you can hire a tutor
and that the more intense it becomes the
more you're actually living it the
faster you're going to pick it up
so if you want to develop the mindset of
the high achiever if you want to become
that person the people that you look up
to the the whoever of the world like I
want to be the next whoever perfect that
person the more you hang around with
them the more it's going to rub off on
you how they think because how they
think how they act how they behave how
they see the world is very different
than how you see it right now and how
the people around you definitely see the
world right now
so how do you do it how do you start to
become it well
I look at what I'm doing
and this was one of my biggest
challenges when I was getting started
and honestly still in like I think the
biggest problem in the world is a lack
of belief
I'm trying to solve the world's biggest
problem people don't believe in
themselves enough I don't you don't
Oprah doesn't people don't believe in
themselves enough for the next level so
how do you start to believe in yourself
more the thing that helped me the most
was to have these successful people
around me constantly
and so I want to share a few tactics
that I think can really help you that
has really helped me as being the shy
introverted kid who never wanted to be
in front of a camera and was making 300
bucks a month and quit on my business
partner and thought life was over right
to now here and it's taken me 20 years
to get here so hopefully we can shorten
that path for you if you actually follow
some of the advice in this video
so step number one how do we create that
environment of Excellence
what you feed into your brain really
really really matters
so figure out how you love to learn for
me it's videos I like to see things I
need to be visual if that's you then you
need to have a way to have those videos
coming into your life every day it can
be part of your morning routine that's
why I make this channel part of your
morning routine subscribe to the channel
every morning every weekday we got a new
video out there for you to give you the
shot events press to help you but if
it's not my channel it's some other
channel one of my other channels
subscribe to the channels that make you
feel bold powerful Unstoppable give you
hope give you belief in yourself
and then watch that video every day or
listen to that podcast every day or read
that book every day the trick is it
can't be the same book or this the one
video because that one video on repeat
is going to lose its Effectiveness right
you know it you watch a video gets you
all fired up and then you watch it again
the next day and it's not as like oh
what happened I don't feel as good and
you watch it the next day and the
feeling's gone so you can't just read
the same book over and over watch the
same video over and over and over again
the key is to find a consistent source
so if you love this channel you love
this video I'm making other videos just
like this
that you can subscribe to if you'd like
an author go find their other books or
go find the people that Inspire them so
that you can read something every day if
you'd like a podcast go find other
podcasts like them so you have something
every day so you you are
manipulating what comes in your head
with intention now
with intention so you're not just
scrolling through things like I am going
to watch one of these videos every day
to slowly shift myself forward because
it'll happen if you love Elon Musk and
you watch Elon Musk every day what will
happen is slowly day by day you will
start to think like Elon Musk it will
happen he will pull you forward you will
start to see the big difference in how
he thinks versus how the people around
you think versus how you think right now
and he will give you more courage and
more boldness and more
a sense of hope and purpose that you can
do it too you'll start to think more
like him so be careful who you pick and
maybe you don't like Elon Musk maybe you
like Kanye West or Oprah Winfrey or
whoever but the more you're around that
person the more you will start to think
like them so you want to put that as
part of your daily routine that every
day because yesterday was a different
day you might have been fired up bold
motivated great but today's today is a
new day
the motivation you had yesterday is
nowhere near what it is right now when
you wake up
right you're the best day of all time
you wake up the next day and it's gone
so how do you keep the consistency the
routine
tell yourself I'm going to watch a video
even when I don't want to even when I
feel low energy even when right all the
excuses we come up with I'm going to
watch a video to get myself into the
state I need to get into because I want
to follow I want to follow my dreams I
don't want to be stuck here anymore
tied to that is then subscribe to the
channels
that make you feel that way so do an
audit
of all of the channels you follow on
YouTube of all the people you follow on
Instagram any way you're spending time
on social
do an audit of who makes you actually
feel more bold
and who makes you just waste time
or who makes you feel bad about yourself
there's some people you probably follow
who when you look at their stuff it
actually makes you feel worse about
yourself unfollow those people
immediately right they don't care about
you so why are you caring about them
and then the people who make you feel
better
follow them subscribe to them so that
when you happen to be on the platform
when you happen to be throwing going
through YouTube or Instagram you see
them and it makes you remember why
you're doing what you do so the first
part of it is a habit we are designing
our routines around this and I'm going
to watch a video every day with my
heroes so that they pull me forward
right we're putting it into our calendar
the second part of it is I'm also going
to subscribe to channels and people that
inspire me so that when I happen to be
on the platforms I'm feeding myself with
things that inspire me and lift me up
instead of waste my time or put me down
okay so that habit that environment
really really matters the second part of
environment to create our environment of
Excellence right is the physical
environment so this office inspires me
this office this was all with intent the
people on the wall behind me we got
Steve Jobs AP giannini my parents
Howard Schultz Kanye West the trophies
uh you know the YouTube stuff the the
getting
my hands wrong here this side you know
the art the art that people drew my book
uh my neck brace from when I broke my
neck like all even the colors on the
wall all of this it inspires me this
inspires me
when I walk into this office I I want to
believe more in myself
I see Steve Jobs staring me down I see
my parents staring me down it's like a
reminder of what I want to do because I
wake up and I and I don't have you know
the the most energy I don't feel super
bold and like let's go take on the day
right I don't have that as soon as I
wake up
but we manufacture it through the habits
and routines but also the actual
physical environment and the beauty
about this is you only have to set it up
once you know I set this up once and
then I walk in and every day I'm being
hit with these messages and reminders of
the person that I want to be
so whether that's a mood board you put
up for yourself where there's people
that inspire you you have to look at the
thing it inspires you to want to push a
little harder it inspires you to want to
believe in yourself and more it inspires
you to want to go off and take some kind
of action today the physical environment
matters a lot and you can control that
so think about think about your office
think about your bedroom think about
your car think about where you're
spending significant time and how much
of that has actually been done with
intent
how much of your physical environment
has been created with intent to make you
believe in yourself more
it matters a lot and then the third
thing really quick is the actual your
outfit the clothes that you wear how you
show up for yourself when I put this on
I remind myself that I'm a superhero
going to work that might sound really
dumb or cheesy but you know what it
works for me I am a superhero going to
work I'm not fighting crime I'm fighting
lack of belief I want people to believe
in themselves more and I'm going to work
when I see there was a green arrow show
I used to watch
and when they were in their their base
in their Lair they always put their
outfits on a mannequin right so they're
when they're off fighting crime they're
in their uniforms but then when they
come back to their base they're in
normal clothes but they put their
outfits on a mannequin so I went and got
myself a mannequin it's it's just you
can't see it but it's just sitting here
off camera I got a mannequin and it's
got my hoodie on it as a reminder that
I'm a superhero going to work every day
and again that might sound really cheesy
or dumb or corny but I like it it works
for me and putting this on every day
instead of just showing up in my pajamas
I just I work from home
you know we've got 30 something people
on the team
I I don't see my team physically that
often most people work from home I could
just show up every day in my pajamas
by putting this on
reminds me that I'm a superhero with a
mission
whether you want to adopt that or not is
up to you but but how you present
yourself for yourself not just for the
camera I'm not putting this on just for
the camera I'm putting this on because
this is what I put on this is for me
I could make a video of my pajamas
that's fine but I'm making this for me I
wear this for me what do you need to do
for you not just because there's some
expectations when your expectations of
yourself become higher than what you
think other people's expectations are
for you that's when the game starts to
change when I'm wearing something just
because of how I think you guys will
perceive me or or some speech I'm doing
or some meeting
I'm I'm only living up to that person's
standard to what I think their standards
are and said no I'm doing this for me I
wear this for me I show up like this
even if I'm not making any kind of
content I only make content once a week
usually for YouTube what are the what am
I doing the other days of the week I'm
still wearing this because I'm a
superhero going to work and it's my
reminder
create an environment of Excellence guys
your environment is keeping you where
you are your environment is keeping you
stuck and if you don't want to be stuck
anymore if you want to change your
circumstances if you don't want to be in
the same spot you are right now one year
from today you have to create an
environment of Excellence
how do we do that number one we start
feeding our mind with Excellence from
the videos and podcasts and books from
people who Inspire Us number two we
change our physical environment so that
you walk into a room you walk into your
car you walk into your bedroom or office
or wherever you're spending time and it
pushes you forward to step into the
person that you want to be and then
number three The Outfits what you wear
how you present yourself having a higher
standard for yourself than what other
people expect that you are a superhero
going to work every day because you are
on a mission
you've got a great heart you've got tons
of ideas
I see it over and over and over and over
and over again
so much potential
and just stuck
stuck
because it's a lack of momentum that
stems from having a really poor
environment
if you can just change with intention
that I am going to create an environment
of Excellence for myself that inspires
me and pushes me forward to step into
the person I want to believe that I can
be
you can do that every day
your entire life will change
foreign
video I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you're different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
it's a special celebration if you put a
hashtag believe down in the comments
Below on this video I will showcase you
and celebrate you somewhere on the
screen in a future video because you are
awesome if you want even more Joe
dispenza check the video right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there the hardest part about change is
not making the same choices you did the
day before period and the moment you
decide to make a different Choice get
ready because it's going to feel
uncomfortable Dr Joe dispenza applies
quantum physics to help people make